this proceeding is also
being televised secretary
we please call the roll
-- Cooley Cunningham
Carillo flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove Maienschein
Mathis quirk Silva Rama
share Rivas yeah Wicks yeah
we have a quorum we have a
quorum we also have a consent
agenda is our motion on the
consent agenda second a move
and this week seconded by
turning your
Mathis please call
the roll the next
Cunningham hi Cunningham I
Carillo flora floor I Grayson
by race and I Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein Mathis Mathis
aye quirk Silva Ramos Ramos I
Rivas Rivas I work side by side
socialist passed the assembly
rules committee is not journal
you can add on this kind of
there's a so I have ordered a
Carillo I don't come here